good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all the world's major
problems I started to believe life
series to try to expand beyond just the
world of entrepreneurship and try to
learn some other skills resources ideas
to help us become maybe a more complete
human being so today we're going to
learn how to survive a hangover and as
always guys if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the count's below and put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well joy
[Music]
and a question for you tell me if this
look is a little familiar to you why if
it is you've probably been hung over if
it's not you have more self-control than
me when it comes to alcohol and probably
a lot of other things
don't think too highly of yourself that
isn't very exciting much for any of you
who've never experienced a hangover
maybe you're underage maybe you're just
boring
imagine the headache that you look at
killer whale has been dropped on your
face now imagine your mouth is a
standing desert now I'm adding crippling
regret and remorse and having no idea
where Liam anywhere they're really
thinking to yourself why would anybody
inflict that kind of pain upon
themselves well welcome to that over to
have to drink a tough water as you're
drinking okay when you drink alcohol
drink the world alcohol someone and it
will save your ass from punishment the
net they know many of you watching this
are probably going with a god
we know this okay could you tell us
something that we don't know could you
teach us something that we don't know
yes everybody knows that you should make
water into your drinking because alcohol
dehydrates but nobody freakin does how
many judges or joke with your friends
and you still drink all night without a
single drop of water I don't want to
drink one of these water fills in the up
okay
it makes me bloat it I just wanted to a
lot of your money you could pay but
that's the next day your eyes will be
over the toilet okay and what is this
the worst feeling in the world right
here when you over toilet like this you
know and you you try to throw
[Music]
I've nothing coming it is not painful
Oh get out with you Lister go ahead
Nicole both of you I am simply tweet me
back into your phone log please Jesus
you feels it you don't be in that
situation I actually have some booths in
my shower at home going running sweating
it out and having a shot of chartreuse
in the shower going for a run or
sweating it out and getting all that
crap out of your system is just
fantastic you go for a run the first 10
minutes are horrible best hangover cure
for me no it is is a sauna or school
room get out of the house your body
starts to work your metabolism starts to
go when you want to sweat out a hangover
there's two options you can either you
know have a whole bunch of spicy food or
you can exercise I choose the food
number 3 sports drinks yeah Garrity
dehydration caused by alcohol is
essentially what causes your hangover
thus it's important to drink as many
fluids as possible the following day to
help rehydrate your body sports drinks
like Gatorade are a popular choice
because they help replenish your body
with electrolytes that it may have lost
thanks to the diuretic effect of alcohol
when you're still a little conscious
morning stocking your fridge with
Gatorade before you go out to the bar
may save you a ton of pain in the
morning
Gatorade now it quenches your thirst
better it tastes better too maybe it's
you you're drinking the wrong water
alright I knew a lot of people swear by
this but trust me if you wake up with a
hangover eating a greasy breakfast is
not the way to go in fact doctors
suggest quite the opposite don't have
anything fatty instead have a breakfast
full of carbs and protein as that will
be much more soothing for your stomach
so have a piece of toast with egg have
some oatmeal and throw in some chopped
apples or have some musk melon with some
yogurt and honey alcohol tends to drain
a lot of potassium from your body so if
you're fighting nausea or a headache eat
a banana bananas are chock full of
potassium so make yourself a banana
and if you like sweeten it with honey
instead of sugar it will make you feel
much better and it will help bring your
blood sugar back to normal
cabbages are rich in fiber and there are
full of vitamins and minerals like
sulfur potassium and iodine all of which
are very good for your body especially
when you have a hangover so try this
boil some cabbage and sit on the cabbage
juice all day long
trust me you'll feel much better my
hangover cure was charcoal pills which
are basically these little pills are
just like they are the set is full of
charcoal they're supposed to absorb is
how they said their work they absorb all
the toxins all the alcohol makes
disperse to your system better take them
before you start drinking I feel I feel
great I don't feel terrible I did one
shot akela as the night went on I asked
for more shots of tequila in the
margarita which is bad idea but I feel
great
I'd say charcoal pills are confirmed
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of this video what was the
message that you took home that you're
going to immediately apply somehow in
your life or maybe in your business
leave it down the couch below I'm really
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to Andre Andre thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word I really hope you
enjoyed the book and I'm so appreciative
for your support so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
have an amazing day we'll see you soon
alright drink ask ensue eat some [ __ ]
rice and seafood and now I feel amazing
it could be argued that soup is alcohols
antithesis it provides sodium water and
other nutrients that alcohol depletes
and since it can be salty you will
likely double down on the h2o which is
an added rehydration bonus soup can also
help with digestion and settle down your
stomach if you're feeling nauseous after
a night of heavy drinking which is
beneficial to people who may find it too
difficult on their stomachs to eat a
meal a bowl of chicken noodle soup can
go a long way to helping you feel back
to normal
wake up at 3 p.m. very slowly do
everything slowly today make sure you
wanna that's it there you go a junkie
roll over and make sure there's no one
else in bed with you if you hangover is
truly horrendous you should be safe no
matter how sexy you filled you with
being on the dance floor last night you
probably see eye to eye off the club and
fell it up on somebody stare up at the
ceiling open mouth and contemplate your
decisions the ones he can remember
anyway get out of bed slowly that's it
upsy-daisy
remember the evil some form of fast food
last night and there's still some
leftover contemplate eating it okay I
mean what okay don't do that well cough
way down the hole and forget what your
reason for getting up was and then
remember and go to the toilet empty you
let up and maybe you started if it's a
cracker phone now make your way to the
kitchen again slowly get some form of
liquid into your body just about
anything will no over no no not that not
that good scientists have said is the
only way to truly recover from a
hangover is to drink double the amount
you drank last night but in Bordeaux the
bay prepares to drain a bus so what are
you doing come on now you hydrated a
little bit
have a seat whereas okay yeah just go do
that around this time some memories of
the night before life start to come back
to you so let's just stay in this
position for a little while and let that
happen
don't fall asleep there still have to
date back to the kitchen from the first
edible packets products you say in fact
you may want to stock up on what you can
now because this might be the last time
during the tape you'll be able to
physically leave your bed retain the bed
with your snacks and preferably a laptop
not the eating your weight and
carbohydrates and watching your weight
in Netflix it's time to go to bed they
get comfortable good night sweet prince
see you next weekend